this is Deadpool - not Titanic Ryan
Reynolds and Celine Dion bring the
laughs in her just released Ash's video
for Deadpool - beat it spider-man god I
should have asked NSYNC
but the actor is now admitting he uses
humor to battle his lifelong struggle
with anxiety
Ryan tells the New York Times quote I
have anxiety I've always had anxiety
I've been to the darker end of the
spectrum which is not fun and he admits
to self-medicating in his 20s I was
partying and just trying to make myself
vanish in some way now 41 years old and
a father of two he says wife Blake
Lively is a source of support quote she
gets me a lot I love what you said about
Blake after you got those two Golden
Globe nominations you called her a de
facto coach what else does she teach you
Oh everything I mean she really does
just show me how to be better in almost
every way as a father as a person
everything Reynolds also says that
meditation and doing press for Deadpool
in character health - I mean Deadpool
and I definitely share a beating heart
[Music]